Let's get started, folks, with another speedrun game.
For those watching on YouTube, I am currently in Oslo, Norway, commentating the Chess Kit Cup.
So apologies in advance for any audio or video problems, but hopefully things hold up.
And we are playing Black against Anik0506.
And as is our custom, we will attempt an Accelerated Dragon.
And finally, we get an Open Sicilian, which has been rare in the speedrun thus far.
We actually have had just a handful of Accelerated Dragons.
Let's see how it holds up against a strong player.
And this is our first Marozzi bind. This is very exciting.
We have not faced the Marozzi bind to date.
At a lower level, it's much more common to play Knight to c3, which is sort of the other main move.
The Marozzi binds, which is characterized by the pawns on e4 and c4, this is a classic bind.
And in general, in chess, a bind is a situation where two or more pawns control a set of key central squares.
In this case, they really only control one square, the d5 square.
But the danger of this positionally is that it is very, very hard for Black to break free in the center with d5.
And so if Black handles this opening improperly, what often happens is that Black's position becomes incredibly cramped.
So it's not like White is trying to checkmate us.
The Marozzi bind is dangerous from a positional standpoint.
Because handled improperly, you get a situation where Black just runs out of ideas
and is basically, you know, hanging around on the bottom two or three ranks.
So the line that I recommend against the Marozzi is not the most popular, Bg7.
It's actually to start with the move, Knight to f6.
Now, of course, the appeal of this move is that it hits the e4 pawn straight away.
And I think our opponent already responds with a somewhat improper move, f3.
Instead, the common response here is Knight b1 to c3, which I'll address separately after the game.
And I'll kind of give you the outline of the system that I recommend.
So I think we can basically do the same thing against the move, f3.
What you want to do here is actually take on d4.
So you invite White's queen to recapture.
And it may seem at first sight that this can only benefit White.
Why is that? Well, it's because the queen on d4 looks unassailable.
But what you should realize, what you should realize...
Oh, apparently I've lost to this guy.
Oh, it's the guy I disconnected against. That's funny.
So there was a speedrun game for those watching on YouTube where I got auto-disconnected
and then it auto-resigned, and it was against this guy.
So I have my chance at revenge.
But what you should notice is that once the bishop is deployed to the long diagonal,
the queen is going to be under very serious fire,
and there's going to be threats of a discovered attack with this knight.
But we don't want to go Bishop g7 immediately,
because we don't want to give White the opportunity to play e5,
because that'll force our knight back to g8,
and why should we allow that kind of stuff, right?
Although, on the other hand, after Bishop g7, e5, knight g8, White is so poorly developed
that that e5 pawn is going to be very hard to hold.
So I actually think that we can start with Bishop g7.
This is a very tricky move.
And my intuition tells me that after e5, knight g8, which is what happens on the board,
White is going to be unable to hold onto his center without that center starting to collapse.
So who can tell me what is the best way of attacking this e5 pawn using the pin against White's queen?
That's kind of the key element of this position, is that pin,
which allows us to put pressure on White's center.
Of course, it's the obvious d6, which is what we should start with.
Bishop f4. Okay, I don't think this is the area I think our opponent is doing
what he did in our previous game, which is just playing instantly and, you know, kind of bluffing.
So let's think here for a second.
Now, of course, we have the option of playing pawn takes pawn.
Then a queen trade is forced, but then White will castle queenside with check
and develop an initiative in the endgame.
In that position, it looks like White's got pretty decent compensation for the pawn.
So that's a backup option.
Now, of course, we have the option of developing the knight to h6 and trying to castle quickly,
but that's a bit anticlimactic because our general strategy is to put pressure on this e5 pawn.
Yeah, there is this very interesting move some of you are suggesting, which is to play queen to a5,
and the idea is to not only pin the knight, but more to the point,
is the fact that it attacks the e5 pawn. It threatens a fork.
But after queen a5, White has the very annoying move, queen to d5.
And that's a hard move for us to deal with because in the event of the queen trade,
White will be threatening knight c7.
So after queen a5, queen d5, we can try to drop our queen back to b6.
Not a bad option, but again, White has this check on b5, forcing the queens off the board.
And again, we're experiencing problems where the knight always threatens to get to the c7 square.
So it's actually quite tricky to play this position.
I'm also looking at some developing moves here.
We don't actually have to make a move to attack this pawn.
We can play a simple move like bishop e6.
So I actually think that that is the most practical option.
Rather than trying to do everything in one move, we can just bring our freaking pieces out.
So bishop e6 is possible.
And then in the event that White castles queen side, then we can play pawn takes e5.
And in contrast to the immediate pawn takes e5, notice that our rook is going to be protecting our queen.
So this is the kind of move which I think a lot of lower-ranked players would find it very difficult to make
because we're not attacking e5. We're not doing what one might think we have to do.
And instead, we're just kind of keeping the tension and making a regular developing move.
And I actually can't believe our opponent is thinking.
Clearly, I'm doing something right then.
I'm also not saying that it's the best move. It might not be the best move.
Now, you might also wonder, well, wait a second.
Why are we not putting our bishop on the quote-unquote more aggressive f5 square?
Now, bishop f5 does not prevent long castles because by rule, it's the king that cannot cross a defended square.
The rook is allowed to cross a defended square.
So in response to bishop f5, White could indeed castle queen side.
What I like about bishop e6, though, is that it does pressure the c4 pawn, which could become important later.
And the second thing it does is it controls the d5 square,
which is a rather annoying jumping off point for White's knight in certain variations.
So I think that we're in pretty good shape here.
In retrospect, maybe it was not the best idea to allow e5.
The classic treatment is to play d6 in order to prevent e5.
So after knight c3, which is the main move, after takes takes, you're supposed to play d6 there.
It's actually very important in that particular version to not allow e5.
The difference here is that White didn't use this move to develop a piece.
So I concluded that we can get away with allowing e5.
So what are we threatening? Okay, queen e4.
That's a good move. It's a great move.
Now, we can start to play tactically here, and I have a very exciting idea.
Now, we shouldn't fall asleep because what is the point of queen e4?
Well, it defends b7, so some of you might be thinking,
oh, well, let's defend the pawn with something like rook b8.
Well, that would be a very, very bad move because White is now able to take on d6.
Why does that favor White? Because you might say, oh, but doesn't that open up our bishop?
Well, if you look more carefully after ed, ed, the cons outweigh the pros
because that d6 pawn becomes an incredibly vulnerable weakness,
and White can castle queenside there, and immediately the d6 pawn collapses,
and our king is going to stay stranded in the center.
So let's not touch that with a 10-foot pole, which gives us essentially one option.
I don't like queen b6 here because that actually invites White to castle queenside, right?
It invites White to do what he wants to do anyway.
So I actually think we have to take on e5 and resolve the tension in the center.
That's going to help us develop our kingside more quickly.
Bishop takes e5. Now, we've got two options.
The first is the sort of mundane option, which equalizes.
The second is the Naroditsky approach, and it's very much in the spirit of the accelerated dragon.
It might be dubious subjectively, but I think we can make it work.
So the simple option is to trade on e5 and then play knight g8 to f6,
and then to castle kingside, and that position is, I think, approximately equal.
The second option, let's see who can come up with it. What else is available to us in this position?
Actually, we have a third option, which might be even better.
Yeah, a lot of you guys are finding it.
It's not f5 because f5 is a very weakening move.
That would be one movitis. The queen just drops back, and what have we achieved, right?
We've merely deprived this bishop of a very important defender.
In the same spirit, the move that I missed initially was bishop to f5. Bishop to f5.
Oh, but white's got a sick tactic there. Oh my gosh.
White can take on b7 there, and after bishop takes bishop,
drop the queen back to b5 and then win the bishop back on e5 with an extra pawn.
Man, I am not getting lucky in this speedrun.
Now, we can go for that line consciously because it accelerates our development,
but in the same spirit, we can also simply play knight f6, queen takes b7 in castle kingside
and try to develop an advantage and then somehow punish white for keeping the king in the center.
So let me think about which option is better.
Yeah, it feels like I did something wrong here.
I have been getting very consistently outplayed in this speedrun in the last couple of games, it seems,
but let's not panic. It might be necessary for us to play bishop takes e5, queen takes e5, and knight f6.
And this is something that constitutes an important skill at a higher level as well,
which is to basically admit, yeah, it's not that I messed up, I don't think I messed up seriously,
but I didn't want to go for this line initially because it's boring
and because giving away your fianchettoed bishop can be a problem.
Now, it should be pointed out that if we compare the placement of the remaining bishops,
our bishop is definitely better than its counterpart.
And the reason I say that is because of this c4 pawn, which is really blunting this bishop on f1.
On the other hand, white's got an active queen, white's got slightly better control of the center,
so this pawn can be considered both a strength and a weakness, which is very common at a higher level.
And of course, also, this pawn on f3 is not, the pawn itself is not a weakness,
of course, as I've pointed out many times, when there's a pawn like this on f3 or on f4,
you always have this idea of playing queen to b6,
and in general, exploiting this diagonal when white casts a short h4.
Our opponent kind of going for the kill here.
I'm not scared of this move because white doesn't have any development here,
so this just cannot work from a perspective of chess principles.
But we should take this idea seriously.
We've got, again, several options.
We could play h5, which would be the move that we play if we respect our opponent's idea.
Alternatively, we could just castle in white's face and allow h5.
It's not entirely a paper tiger.
Like, this could get very dangerous for us, but I'm just very scared.
I mean, it's hard to refute our opponent's play.
We could then just play queen to d6 and trade queens and try to win the endgame.
That would be an option.
Actually, I don't dislike that option.
Let's start by castling, so let's start by completing our development.
There's no way that h5 directly leads to checkmate.
I called BS on that.
Okay, so what are our options here?
Well, we can play knight takes h5, and that's a hard move to evaluate.
Definitely we don't get mated right away after knight takes h5.
What worries me about that move is the long-term problems along the h file,
but I did just come up with a cool defensive idea.
So what is white likely to do after knight takes h5?
Well, I think the obvious move there is g4,
but after g4, we drop our knight back to f6,
and we ask, well, what has white really achieved from sacrificing that pawn?
The queen could then drop back to h2,
but the h7 pawn would be very well protected by our knight,
and that in general would not be a scary type of idea.
I think that we should call BS on this and take this pawn fearlessly.
I don't see a clear follow-up for white. I just don't see it.
Maybe something exists, but I do not see it.
Well, if he takes the knight, then we take back,
and I don't see a follow-up there either.
I don't think there's checkmate.
Our opponent is probably going to opt for something like that
that would be consistent with what he's been doing,
but I'm kind of calling the bluff here.
Yeah, so maybe there's some sort of hidden tactic.
I don't rule that out at all.
Again, entirely possible that there's some perpetual there
or there's some line that leads to a strong attack,
but our opponent doesn't go for it, and this was my idea.
This is the move that initially caused me to rule out knight takes h5,
but I think there's a brilliant defensive move in this position.
How do you find this defensive move?
Well, you should always have a wish list in mind,
and I've talked about this before.
What are the items that you want to achieve
to further the causes of your position?
I think the top item on the wish list,
and this should be obvious to everybody, is a queen trade.
If we can trade queens, then we're simply up a pawn in the endgame.
The moment you tell yourself that this move should become
maybe not obvious, but you should at least be on your radar,
and that's queen d8 to b8,
which is not hard to see conceptually.
There's different types of difficulty in chess.
There's conceptual difficulty where a move might be easy to see,
but it might be hard to understand why it's good.
This is the kind of move that when it's played,
everybody says, ah, well, of course, queen b8,
but it can be hard to see geometrically
because you don't make this move often,
and a lot of you might have been tempted by a move like queen to b6,
which I think would have been incredibly dangerous.
The additional benefit of this move is that
if white declines the queen trade with queen to g5,
how should we proceed in that position?
This is the sort of second part of our idea,
insisting on your concept.
Queen g3, exactly, queen g3.
Now, queen f4 would be a blunder there
because of rook takes h5,
grabbing the knight and protecting the queen at the same time,
a very, very common type of blunder.
But in the same vein, queen g5, queen g3 check forces the queen,
and after our knight gets to g3, don't stop calculating there.
Notice that white experiences problems with this pawn on c4
because we will be then threatening to take on f1
and take on c4 with two extra pawns.
Now you might say, well, white can move rook h4 in that position.
That's some high-level calculation,
but you don't have to calculate any further
because we know for a fact that we are up a pawn
and we're chilling in that position.
So if white plays rook h5 now,
then we will take back on h5.
White has a check on g5,
but after king h8, I don't see a follow-up,
and it occurs to me now that white did have a draw in the previous position.
White could have drawn the game here by force
with a very, very advanced tactical concept,
which I'll show you after the game,
but it did in fact start with rook takes h5.
So at this point, I think we're very much in control of the game.
And that is obviously a good sign.
Now that doesn't mean we've won. We're just up a pawn.
But we're up a pawn, and we still have the advantage
of our superior bishop.
Our knight on h5 suddenly becomes an asset
rather than a deficiency
because it's threatening to jump onto one of these weak dark squares,
and it's just nicely played.
I mean, it could come back to f6 at any time
and kind of rejoin society,
but it's doing well on this little island here.
And our bishop is also doing a great job
because it's taking the sting out of the move knight to d5,
simply bishop takes d5.
So again, to convert such endgames,
which is one of the hardest skills in chess,
when you should never feel bad when you fail to convert
an endgame like this, right, where you're, let's say, up a pawn,
because it's genuinely very, very difficult,
and white has some assets too.
I mean, his pieces are active. He's got a pawn majority.
It's just we've got an extra pawn on the other side of the board.
So this requires tremendous precision.
I'm going to accelerate a little bit here
because we're kind of low on time.
Broadly speaking, of course, we want to trade pieces, right?
That's a pretty straightforward statement.
We want to trade pieces.
If we can get all of the rooks off the board,
I think it'll be easier for us
to sort of convert our four-on-two
pawn majority on the king side.
So there's a couple of ideas here.
We can throw the knight onto g3.
That's one option.
But then white will play bishop d3.
The knight could potentially be maneuvered back to f5,
but I'm not totally convinced
that the trade of bishop for knight is positive for us.
I think that we should make a less committal move
and just play rook fd8.
I think we should keep our trump cards in our pocket
and keep the knight on h5,
and we should get a pair of rooks off the board.
Now the downside of this approach
is that we've given up the d-file.
But if you look more carefully, this bishop is really a hero
because it's holding this penetration square on d7.
Yeah, white has the d-file,
but I don't think that white has a lot that he can gain
from the control over the d-file.
Now we can do a couple of different things.
In general, our opponent's plan
is probably to start pushing his pawn majority
with something like c5.
So a move that occurs to me as a kind of prophylactic measure
is to play b6 and try to halt the progress of the pawn.
Alternatively, rook c8 comes to mind,
but that's a little bit passive.
We can still play knight g3.
Possibly white will play bishop d3 there,
and maybe in that position
we can already consider knight f5.
Although, again, I'm not totally sure
who benefits with that trade.
I think it might be us, though.
Yeah, I'm inclined to play knight g3.
I think now's the time to reap the rewards of our knight,
and I think that we should play knight f5
and essentially ask white a question.
Okay, our opponent is answering questions
very quickly in this game.
We have a bishop versus knight position.
What changed my mind is that we've traded a pair of rooks.
I think with only one pair of rooks on the board,
white's rook and knight look very impressive,
but again, all that white can really do here
is pose one-move threats,
and that's what our opponent is doing.
Obviously, we drop our bishop back to e6.
There's no other squares, and knight d5.
Okay, so that asks us a big question.
Do we want to trade bishop for knight?
And your answer should not just be yes uncritically
because after bishop takes knight, rook takes bishop,
what's the complicating factor in that rook endgame?
Well, it's the fact that white is infiltrating
the 7th rank by force, which is a big deal.
But upon closer examination,
I think that we can actually keep the rook
away from the 7th rank.
How? By playing what move?
King f8 there.
And if white still drops the rook on the 7th rank,
what's our strategy there?
It's a defensive strategy.
So bishop takes d5, rook takes d5, king f8, rook d7.
We go king e8, rook c7, king d8,
and we drive the rook out of that 7th rank,
and that should already be winning.
So I think we should take.
Maybe our opponent will take back. No, okay.
And we should go king f8.
Now, more broadly, what we want to do is go king e8
and then trade the rooks.
And pawn endgames are going to be winning most of them.
Although if you've watched my pawn endgame videos,
you will know that there is a complicating factor
on the king side, unfortunately.
What is it? What can white do
to try to make it difficult for us
to exploit our pawn majority?
What move can white potentially make at some point?
Yeah, so white can do what's called the deep freeze,
and that's where one pawn
stops two or more pawns from advancing.
And this is the most common type of deep freeze,
a very advanced move, g5, not easy to make,
because you have to understand why you're making it.
You're making it to halt the progress of the h-pawn.
h5 then, of course, meets with en passant.
So even some of those pawn endgames,
and I have some examples,
you could have a pawn endgame where you're up
to even two or even three pawns,
but because there's a deep freeze situation,
the pawn majority on the other flank decides the game.
So we shouldn't just uncritically go for that rook endgame.
Now, deep freezes can be fought, right?
This g5 pawn could be contested with a timely f6,
but then white could play f4.
So we'll have to calculate pawn endgames concretely.
So given the opportunity,
we might actually want to play h6,
so that if white ever plays g5,
well, we take the sting out of it,
and we can actually play that now,
but we could also go king e8.
So what's more important?
Well, it's hard to say.
That requires some calculation over everything,
as Canty says.
Now, my temptation is to bring our king into the game.
Yeah, I think we should do that.
I think we should start with king e8.
And I'm really not sure.
Okay, now we can again play h6
and hold off the pawn majority.
We could play e6 and chase the rook away.
That's an interesting option.
We could play rook d8,
but again, I'm not convinced that that pawn endgame
is winning because of this g5 idea,
which is quite annoying.
So definitely we shouldn't hurry.
I think we should play h6,
but oh, but then we can go rook d1 and rook h1.
Wow.
That's nuts.
So maybe f6 is a better way to do the same thing.
Maybe f6 is an interesting approach here.
Man, this is not easy.
e6 is possible as well.
Rook d1, king e7, rook h1, rook h5,
and white de-freezes us again.
But then we play e5.
No, I think that one's winning.
Oh, so e6 is a very good-looking move.
Yeah, I think we should go e6
and just get this rook off of d5.
This also forces white to kind of decide
where he wants to keep the rook
because if he keeps it on the fifth rank,
then potentially he gives us the d-file.
Well, asking questions like these is always a good idea.
Now, I have a higher-level plan in mind.
Here's the ideal scenario.
Again, it's the sort of wishlist method
where you say, okay,
what do I want to achieve in the ideal scenario?
Well, ideally, we want one of two things.
Either we want a pawn endgame
where we don't have a deep freeze situation,
so in some way we've prevented g5.
That would be winning
because the four-on-two-pawn majority
will beat the three-on-two-pawn majority
on the other side.
But the second wishlist item
is a situation where we create
a passed h-pawn
and get this b8 rook over to h8.
That would basically end the game right away.
Those types of situations are almost always winning
in rook endgames,
and I'll show you kind of a stock example
of that after the game.
There's a famous classical game that really
shows the extent to which
that situation often decides
the game in a rook endgame.
So, after rook to d1,
you would be forgiven for thinking
let's play h5, let's go, let's create the passer,
but if you calculate after g8,
g8, rook h1,
the rook can't jump over the king.
That is why after rook d1
we have to go king e7.
If, after that, white plays
rook h1 and hits the h7 pawn,
we are just in time to play
rook to h8, and what do we threaten
after we play rook h8?
And what do you think white should do
in response to that? Just testing your understanding.
Okay, rook b5.
The move there was, of course, h5.
Right, so once we play rook h8,
we're ready to play h5.
Our opponent is taking a fundamentally different approach.
He is trying to hold off the move h5,
and I think this is the best move.
Okay, so let's think.
Again, we have options.
I think here we should take the opportunity
to play h6.
This is the time that we should play h6.
The reason why is that if instead
you play a move like king to d7,
and maybe we should have played a6.
Now that I think about it,
yeah, maybe a6 is better,
but it doesn't really matter.
The thing is, white was threatening to play g5 there.
Now I think we're in great shape,
but we have to be extremely precise.
This guy is
wildly, wildly underrated.
Let's see.
I think that we should go king e7,
but I'm not sure.
Well, we have to bring our king up
some way,
because if we give a check on d8,
we simply help white's king get closer
to our side of the territory.
So the ultimate choice here is between
king d7 and king e7,
and my intuition tells me that we should
stay a little bit closer to our kingside pawns.
Now we're very, very close
to being able to create a passer,
either with h5,
and in order to be able to play h5,
we're going to have to kick this rook off the 5th rank,
so in our pocket, we have this move,
a6, which we can throw in
essentially when we're ready to play h5,
which is now.
But white is very active here,
so there are some complicating factors.
The king is super active.
Of course, the rook is pressuring b7,
and we want to be careful about playing b6.
I mean, maybe that was the best move,
and actually that was the best move, wasn't it?
Should have played b6, simply.
For some reason, I thought c5 was a problem,
but it's not, because bc is a check.
It's late.
I'm missing some details in this endgame,
but I still think we're winning.
Yeah, but our opponent,
this guy is
incredibly sharp.
Incredibly sharp.
He punishes us for not playing b6.
But it's not
the end of the world.
Far from the end of the world.
We have a choice here,
because c6 is not a serious threat, actually.
c6 is not a threat at all.
So we have options.
We can play f6,
which is an ugly looking move.
But the benefit of f6,
why would we do that?
Well, it would be to prevent white's king
from infiltrating e5.
We can also play Rd8, Rd7,
and essentially shift the positioning of our rook,
so that in addition to defending b7,
it is also doing something productive
and keeping white's king away.
I think there are multiple ways to win here.
I really like the look of Rd8 and Rd7.
I also like the look of h5.
Basically not procrastinating.
But then if our rook gets stuck here,
that might be an issue.
Because eventually we'll need to go
Kd7, Kc6 to get that rook behind the pawn.
So man, this is really hard.
Okay, let's go Rd8 check.
This is what my intuition tells me to do.
h5 might be committing a little too early,
I agree.
But these are...
Hopefully if you're newer to chess,
you're beginning to see through the lens of this endgame
why rook endgames are considered
so complex and hard to learn.
It's because in the middlegame,
the position, you have these things that you can hold onto
to make sense of the position.
In rook endgames,
there's always 5 or 7 candidate moves
and all of them look reasonable
and all of them adhere to different plans.
Like, do you start by creating a passer?
Do you improve the position of the rook?
Do you improve your pawn structure on the kingside?
There's so many things that you can do
and all of them seem approximately equivalent.
And very often there's only one winning path.
So you're essentially relying
in most cases purely on your intuition
and on a little bit of calculation.
And most of the calculation
that you do in rook endgames
involves figuring out who wins
so a pawn endgame, that's called liquidation
and it's sometimes calculating
pawn races and concrete things
like that.
So, rook endgames are incredibly hard
almost nobody can play
them without mistakes.
Magnus, definitely the best rook endgame
player of all time. Capablanca was well known
for that as well.
So it's very very hard to play without blundering.
I'll give you some recommendations
on endgames after the game,
but here I have to focus
because two and a half minutes
is not a lot of time.
King e4, best move.
Okay, so we could play
f5 check. See, again, we could play
this move or we could not play this move.
I don't think there's a hurry to play f5
because we could always play it on the next move.
Again, white cannot deep freeze us anymore
because we played this move, h6.
So let's see what happens.
We played this move, h6.
So,
broadly, our plan is now
to exploit our pawn majority, f4.
So white is trying to go g5 here
so we shouldn't fall asleep. Although g5 could
be met with h5, but I still don't like that
scenario because then our remaining three pawns
are going to be essentially immobilized.
So I like the
look of f5 check,
but then white takes it, we take back.
White drops back
because white does get mated after king e5, rook d5.
And then we can
go king f6 and we've made some progress
and we're ready to push the h-pawn.
And that's one option.
We can also start with h5
or we could play king f6
and use our king to kind of shield
ourselves from these pawns.
But king f6 is quite unwieldy because
we essentially put our king in front of our own
pawns. Let's break through with f5.
I think this is our chance to do it.
Our opponent finding all the tricky
lines here. Let's take with the g-pawn.
Of course, king e5,
rook d5 is checkmate, so white has to drop
back. And then
I think we need to make one more move
before we are ready to start pushing
the h-pawn. This might be a draw.
I mean, we're basically playing
at this point for two results, which is really
a pleasant feeling.
But still, if white defends this accurately,
I think he should be able to draw this.
Yeah, king f6. And king f6 is a
pretty intuitive move for experienced endgame
players. There are several ideas of this move.
One of them is finally
to open up the pathway for the rook to
drop to h7, which is the best square on the board.
This is why, you know,
your rook can make or break your endgame
experience, because on a square like h7
it's both attacking and defending at the
same time. The second thing that we should
consider doing is pushing while we have a
chance. Because here's the thing.
After h5, king f3,
h4, our pawn
is itself cutting off white's
king from its ability to stop
that pawn by stepping in front of it. So
white could go king g2,
rook h7, king h3.
But then perhaps we create a second
pass pawn with e5. So we want to
make this move e5, but we want to
do it at a strategic moment.
So I think we should start
by pushing h5,
drive this pawn up as far as it'll
go, put the rook behind it,
or maybe play e5 on the next move or something like
that. But e5 is not going anywhere
for the time being.
I think white's best move, and this is
an incredibly advanced move, is
actually king f2.
Okay.
Let's think about this. h4,
king g2,
g3.
There's so much calculation to do here.
h4,
king g2,
e5,
kxdx,
e3,
cut him off. I should be winning here.
Should be winning here. I think
we should go
h4.
He's probably going to go king g2.
And then I think we should go e5.
I think that's the right moment to play e5.
Now he goes rook h3. That should be a mistake.
Now we have a check on d2 here.
Oh, but he's out-calculated me.
We can also go rook h7
by the way, which is a backup option.
Rook d2, king e3,
takes b2, rook takes there,
there, there,
there. That might be a draw
actually. So I think
man,
I missed that detail there
that I'll show you after the game. Let's go rook h7.
Let's go rook h7.
And try to
put the rook behind the pawn. I mean, that's the obvious move.
Rook h7 is obvious. Of course,
there was also rook d2 check, which is what I was relying on.
I don't think it works.
Again, I'm making these judgments fully intuitively.
Yeah, I don't know. This guy is 24-20.
I mean, I would say he's IM strength
or maybe FM strength.
I mean, I'm not playing perfectly,
but yeah, he's very, very strong.
But legit. I mean, I think he is legit.
I just think he's
extremely underrated.
No, I won't flag. I mean, I might not win this game,
but I won't flag. And now we play e5.
So again, this was the last chance for us
to get on the train. Because if white
had been able to go king d4,
then we wouldn't have been able to
play e5. So we can't miss that opportunity.
It should be winning for black.
I mean, definitely the position is winning.
Can I convert it with a minute on my clock?
Now, what is it that we want to achieve here?
Well, what we want to achieve
broadly is we want to force this
rook to move. Because every time
we force the rook to move, our
pawn is able to advance one square
further and tie the rook down even
further. Ultimately, we want a situation
where the pawn reaches h2
and white's rook is
relegated to h1.
When that scenario occurs,
we can basically
use that pawn as a bargaining chip,
give it away, but give it
away in order to transition to a
pawn endgame. This is the standard technique for winning
such positions, where the rook
is behind the pawn. And then, in
the resulting scenario, white's king
is going to be, you know, in timber 2,
and we're going to converge
on these three pawns with our
own king. Sounds very
complicated, but I'll show you. Once I start showing
you this technique after the game,
you'll understand immediately what I'm talking
about.
Now, what
are the complicating factors here? Well, the issue
is that white is not obliged to move
the rook from h3. White has other moves. White is not
in zugzwang, in other words. White has
two types of moves that he can make.
White can try to preemptively start pushing
the pawns, which is, I think, the most challenging, and of course
our opponent plays it.
Now we have to decide
whether we're slowing white down
or whether we're pushing. And these
are very hard decisions to make.
They require tremendous
calculation.
So there's
Kd5 there, there.
It's a weird
construction, but in my view, what we need...
Okay, let's go Kd5.
Let's go Kd5.
Of course,
it is possible. And now Rh5.
This is the construction that I came up with. This actually
might be a genius idea. Look at this
rook. It's doing three
things. It's guarding h4 and f5,
and it's preventing white's king
from infiltrating further. So it's keeping the king at
bay, and it's keeping the rook at
bay indirectly, because any time the rook
moves, our pawn moves forward.
But I'm delegating to my
king a very important responsibility. I'm
basically leaving the king on its
own, and our king's job
is going to be twofold. I mean, first of all,
it not only has to keep white's pawn majority
restrained. That's not enough. Remember
our ultimate goal here, which is to
essentially induce Zugzwang
and force white to
move this rook away from h3
so that we can start pushing our h-pawn.
How are we going
to induce that scenario? We're going to
basically try to freeze white's pawn majority.
And we've already
come very, very close to achieving that, because
b5 is impossible, because
if king takes c5.
So white can push the a-pawn, but we
can basically wait it out. After a4,
we can play a6.
And then if white plays a5,
then he basically deep freezes his
own pawn majority, and then we've
clearly succeeded, right?
So the only other option
is for white to drop the king back.
Clearly that signifies progress,
and then we can use our own king
to infiltrate and start posing
threats against white's pawn majority.
White's ability to defend those pawns
is restrained greatly by the fact that his
rook can't move. So here
I think it's important not to play king c4,
but to basically wait it out with the move
a6.
And only when white plays a4
do we infiltrate with the king.
What was the downside? Okay, we need to focus.
I don't see it. King c4, d7, h3,
b7, h2 wins. I think our opponent
is trying to bluff it. Oh!
But now I think we need to, okay,
so how do we do this? a5 is possible.
a5 might be winning
on the spot here. Let me calculate.
a5, b8, king takes c5,
king e5,
king b5, king d6,
king takes a5, king c7,
rook h7.
Oh!
Alternatively,
we can play king d4
first. We can play king d4 first
and only when white plays
king f3 do we play a5.
That is possible.
But I don't think it's necessary.
a5, c6,
bc, ba,
king b5.
I think we should play a5 here.
I mean, this is
basically tempo for tempo.
It might be a draw,
but if white draws this,
listen, I'm happy to tip my hat
because I am doing everything
within my power for us to win this game.
Now the basic idea
here to understand is that again,
any time white's rook moves,
unless white moves away with a check,
then we automatically push h3.
And because of the placement
of white's king,
we've created
a situation where the king is
incapable of getting behind the pawn.
It's always going to be one tempo short.
So we don't have to worry about a scenario
where white moves the rook away and then gets the king to h2
because that's not possible mathematically.
If the rook moves, we go h3,
king g3, h2, and the pawn
squeezes through.
It's also very important for us to keep
this b7 pawn alive at all costs.
This is a harder point to understand.
Now why do I say that? Because if
white is able to liquidate
all of the queenside pawns,
then our kingside pawns, even if there's
two of them, might not be enough for us
to win because our king presumably
would be a little bit too far away from the kingside.
That would still be very close,
but that might conceivably be a draw.
Now this is a very
interesting game, actually. I think this is going to be
a worthy speedrun game after a long
absence, but our work is not done.
I'm 20 seconds.
Got to play fast here.
But really, you should notice how
incredibly powerful this rook is
on h5. It's doing everything.
And so
if we win this game, then a big part
of it would have been our ability to find
good squares for the rook at the right
time.
So what is our next move? Especially
when you're in time pressure,
you should have a roadmap
in mind. So against
a waiting move like Ke3, what's
our next move going to be? Well, it's probably going
to be Kb5. If white plays
a4, then of course we play Kb4.
So our next step is to eliminate the
a5 pawn. That's the low-hanging fruit.
Now what's crazy is that white could
say, okay, I'm going to give up the a5 pawn,
and white's h3 rook
is also on a very good spot
because it's defending the other a pawn,
making it hard for us to win it,
and
it's essentially keeping black's king at bay
and not allowing us to infiltrate
through the backside.
So we're going to have to do some maneuvering
there and figure out a way
to maybe sacrifice one of these
pawns in order to win the a pawn.
That's all going to be really tough in time pressure,
but white is now down to two and a half minutes, so finally
our opponent is feeling the heat on the
clock here.
Ke5, which is exactly
what I expected. Oh!
Our opponent
found a brilliant idea. This might draw.
Kb5.
But maybe not.
So we do what we have
to do. There's Kf6.
My
goodness, this guy.
Kf6 and Kg6
like this.
The thing is, white will win one of the kingside pawns,
but he might not be in time.
No, he goes a6.
Okay, wait.
What do we take with?
Believe it or not, I'm very
much inclined to take with the king because
in general, in such positions, you want to have the b pawn,
the corner pawn, is often a
serious weakness.
On the other hand, Ba might be good because then
we'll be able to play Ka4, but okay,
I think he's collapsing here.
But he's making me prove it on the clock.
Okay, Ka5. Let's advance our king.
Now, our next target position
is to play b5 and Ka4.
Our opponent misses the best defense there,
which was Kf6.
Now again, the golden
rule of this endgame is that
we're keeping our king specifically
on the a file so that the rook is unable
to move away with check.
That's the thing. Our next move
is likely to be b5.
Why are we advancing the pawn? Well, we're preparing
for a scenario that I'm kind of predicting will
eventually come, which is a scenario
in which these pawns are not likely to win the game
because they're being restrained.
In order to win the game, we will ultimately
have to win the a3 pawn.
To win the a3 pawn, we might have to part ways
with either the f pawn or the h pawn.
We're going to have to do it very strategically,
not just randomly.
The first step in anything is to get our king
to a4 so that it's making contact
with this pawn. Then the second
logical step is to shift
the b pawn up to b5,
preparing for the scenario
when we win the a3 pawn
because then this pawn is going to be closer to promotion.
You also do this in a lot of pawn endgames,
and it's a very, very important technique.
There we go. There's b5.
There's b5.
We might have just gotten zooged.
King f4
weren't zooged. I should have played b6.
That would have been more subtle.
But I think we'll figure it out here.
It's winning.
I think I know how,
and it's going to be very close.
No, I'll show you.
I figured out a way.
I think I figured out the win.
The thing is,
with increment, we have to be very careful
because if we mess it up, white will have enough time
to hold.
But I think I was able to figure out the win here.
Of course, he plays it.
Now we have to sack the pawn.
Now here, here,
here, here.
That might be a draw.
We can also go rook e8 and try to cut the king off.
That's the thing. We have to cut this king off
and prevent it from reaching the queenside.
So maybe this idea
comes through.
That's to sit.
Yeah, let's go rook e8.
Let's go rook e8.
No, definitely not b4. That would be the worst move in the position.
Again,
what I've predicted has come true.
We have to cling to this pawn at all costs.
If we lose the b pawn, we draw the game.
Now if white takes h4,
this is an easy win because it's basically
a Lucina position.
This is an easy win.
This was already lost because
eventually we would have gotten to that pawn.
Now it's quite easy. We just push our pawn
and this is like a standard Lucina.
You don't even need the Lucina position here
because the king is so far away from the pawn
the Lucina is required
when the king is two files closer.
When the king is this cut off,
you can win this in a million different ways.
The easiest,
notice what I'm doing here.
I'm bringing the pawn as close as it's possible
to the king. Now where newer players
struggle is they always try
to move away from the pawn because intuitively
you might say, well,
I don't want to step in front of the pawn
because I don't want to block its path to the
promotion square. The problem is that if you
play king to d2 here,
white can keep checking you and white
can shift the rook back to the b file
and constantly attack this pawn. That's a drawing
technique in a lot of end games.
You do step in front of the pawn
but you do it so that the pawn can reach
the king rank. And now the final stage
of the conversion process. Again, you don't
need to build a bridge or anything like that.
There's a much simpler way to win the game
when the king is this cut off.
Who knows what the easiest technique to winning is
to finish it off.
Rook e2, yeah, it's possible, but
even simpler is actually
just to play rook to a8
and you can also play rook to c8.
It's the same exact concept
and that's it. Now you move the king over to a1
and the reason you needed that move
was to prevent this check on a5
which would have sent our king right back to b1.
As it stands, white's king is
too far away. We promote to a queen
and we win the game.
That was a tough one.
A lot of stages to that game and I definitely
had my sloppy moments but I thought I played
the end game very well. Of course, the computer
is probably going to laugh at me.
I'm curious about the accuracy.
I want to be laughed at.
Laughed at?
Yeah, there's a lot to talk about.
A lot we have to unpack here.
90.5
to 86.1. High level game.
I will be using
stockfish on my chess base for
some analysis.
I'm just going to copy this game over to chess base.
I also use that for opening analysis.
Alright.
Let's delve right in.
The Marozzi bind characterized by the move
c4. Named after
Orzeza Marozzi, was a Hungarian
player. I think lived in the
19th century, maybe to the early
20th. Was a very strong player
but really was the first to develop this line.
I would say at a grandmaster
level, the Marozzi bind is the biggest
reason why the accelerated
dragon isn't more popular.
Now, there are two reasons why
at lower levels, this is not a particularly
scary line. The first
is that it requires white to play positionally.
Very positionally.
The second is that black has a lot
of tricky responses to the Marozzi
which most players really under
2200 or so do not know.
If white doesn't know them, then white's
center can collapse. White is biting off
a very big part of the cake.
If white does not develop very artfully,
many is the scenario
where you develop your pieces and white
just totally collapses in the center.
In fact, this is what happens in
most games featuring intermediate players
where black is well-versed in
tricky accelerated lines.
To get to the point, knight f6
is tricky and we've already played this
once, I think. In that game, our
opponent immediately fell into their first trap
which is to take on c6 and to play
e5. This is a very tempting move
but any time you have this situation
you have to, of course, remember
that we have queen a5 check.
Don't forget this trap. This is
super important. Of course,
we pick up the pawn on e5 and here black is
easily a healthy pawn up and then
we go bishop g7, we castle
and we can easily advance d5. The queen
can always drop back to this envelope
on c7. It's also common in the Scandi.
So we can chill on e5
but then when white plays
for instance, rook e1,
we don't have to but an easy way
to guarantee safety is to play queen c7.
So that
doesn't work. Now if white takes
and then goes knight c3,
then, as I've explained many times before,
this trade favors black. This c6
pawn is now a great positional asset because
it's holding this knight at bay and we've
got this semi-open b-file
and this is just a very comfortable position for black
as well. So the main
move here is knight to c3. f3 I think
is already a serious inaccuracy and I will
check the best way to fight against it. I've never
analyzed f3 so
maybe knight takes d4
is an inaccuracy in response.
So knight c3, my recommended
line, is knight takes d4, queen
takes d4. Now not
bishop g7 because here e5
is very dangerous but instead
you have to remember to play d6.
Super, super tricky sideline.
Now, to
explain why it's a tricky sideline, first of all
the sort of important thing to
understand is that e5 is no longer dangerous
because after we take on e5,
white can take on d8. Yes,
we lose castling rights but the
reality is that white
does not garner sufficient compensation for the
pawn. And you should remember
in such positions, I know I make
fun of that phrase, I'm going to verify
this with the engine.
What a lot of people are afraid of in these types
of situations is
let's say a move like bishop to e3
and white's going to castle queenside
and it's going to be a check.
But that's just not that dangerous. That engine move
here in fact is just to ignore
everything and hit the bishop with knight g4.
And big deal,
white castles queenside, you block with the bishop.
Yeah, you're self-pinning
but white has no way to put pressure on this bishop.
You might say, well, what about this move
threatening bishop b5? Again,
you should not be afraid, particularly
at this level, of one-move threats.
They're not dangerous. After
knight takes e3, f takes e3, the engine
finds a brilliant way to
defend against the threat. Bishop h6
is possible, and who can tell me,
if you're watching on YouTube, pause and figure this out,
why does bishop b5 not win a piece?
Easy but very pretty.
What's America Marty Wolfman for the subs?
Yeah, bishop
takes e3, check. The bishop drops back
to d4 and intercepts
the rook. Incredible.
And black emerges with two extra
pawns. Now apparently this position
is still equal, but white has to play
this like an engine. Practically speaking,
I think black is doing great here.
The more common move is going to be queen
takes e5, but again, obviously this is very good
for black because the center has opened.
White's got weaknesses on the d-file. The queen
is now very vulnerable, and our next
move is going to be castle.
You can basically play this without analysis,
but to give you a sample
line, and there's no question
that queen takes queen is a better move than
queen takes e5. If white plays bishop
e2, we castle. White
castles, and one important
point about playing
these types of accelerated positions as we did
in the game is not to rush to try
to give a discovered attack to the queen.
A lot of you might be tempted by a move
like knight g4. Again,
this is one moveitis.
A move is not strong because it poses a threat.
In fact, it helps the queen get back
to a safer square,
and if you get too obsessed with this, you're going
to end up paying the price for
these myopic moves.
Instead, in the spirit
of what we did in the game, the best move is bishop
to e6. Again, just developing
the bishop, and actually this now
poses a threat of a discovered
attack. So if white sleeps through
this moment, then we have this very powerful
move, knight to d5, and we're
able to take on c3, or even to
garner the bishop pair with knight takes e3.
If white plays rook d1, again,
it's just a one-move threat. We can still
play knight d5, which is
a brazen-looking move, but we hit the queen,
and the point is that after queen
g3, we can solve our problems
tactically with knight takes knight,
and if white plays rook takes d8,
then knight takes c2 check picks up the queen
and then picks up the rook.
Of course, white has to play
bc, and we develop
the queen to a5, and black is much better.
So you can dig around here on your own if you want
a fuller understanding.
You're not going to face the movie 5 that often,
though. White
has many setups here, and I could spend an hour just
talking about the theory of this line.
But let me show you what happens in
most games at sort of the lower levels.
I can check Leech S for the most common move.
But most people, they basically
just develop their pieces. They play bishop
e2. When I faced this line with white for
the first time, this is also what I did.
Bishop e2 and bishop e3 is a
super common setup. It's not bad. I mean,
it's one of the main lines, but it's not the most ambitious
either. Now after castles,
we reach the first important moment.
A lot of people castle here. Black is
already better. What should black
do, who can tell me, after
white castles? You should not be looking for a tactic
here. You should be looking for a
positionally improving trade.
Not Nd7.
Not b6.
So I've scared you away from
delivering discovered attacks, but here you
do have a good discovered attack, Ng4.
Why? Well, because
we're able to pick off the bishop. Why does that
benefit black? Well, it benefits black pretty
intuitively, because now we have this uncontested
dark-squared bishop, and look at
how weak white's dark-squared bishops
are. Hopefully you're already gaining enough of an understanding
to know what the next move
is likely to be. Where does
the bishop on c8 belong?
Well, it belongs on e6,
hitting the c4-pawn.
Now let's say that white plays a move
like b3. Well, now
we have actually a very powerful
move, Qb6,
which is another sexy idea. Very
sexy idea. And in the event
of the queen trade, we open up the a-file,
and we have an attack on c3.
Let's say white defends.
Now we can play even the move
b5, which really shows you
the power of the accelerated when it
fires on all cylinders. Of course, it's a pretty cooperative
line, but here white can essentially
resign, because he's losing material.
Right, so it's this
power of the bishops,
and
definitely white has to move the queen for that
reason, so Qd2 is the main move, and the best
move. You know, once you have your feet
under you, the moves become quite easy.
Here you play Bb6,
and develop your bishop. And most
people in this position, of course, they castle kings.
If white analyzes this with an engine, then he
can potentially play better. Now there are several moves
in this position that you can try,
but the main move is Qa5.
You basically bring the queen out,
and put more pressure on white's queen side.
And I claim that this position is very
very hard to play for white, if he's
not very well versed in the theory.
So a couple of
examples to illustrate how
dangerous this can be. A lot of people get very
tempted by this tactic, Nd5,
which is a common tactic, but it doesn't work here,
because after the take, trade
on d2. White takes on e7, intermezzo,
but the line doesn't end here.
Black plays Nxc4, and
develops a huge initiative. The knight is stranded,
everything's hanging, this is better for black.
So that's one line
to remember. Now, if white
plays b3, because a lot of people are tempted
to reinforce
the c4 pawn, b3 is a good move.
And black has a couple of options
here, but the best is to
play Rf to c8.
Again, let's say white plays
a move like f3 and sleepwalks
through this moment. Well, already
black develops a huge initiative
on the queen side by playing a6.
What are we preparing? We're
preparing the move b5. Why is that
move dangerous? Because after b5, white is unable
to take, because the knight on c3
hangs. So let's say white says,
okay, well I'm going to go Rc1, and I'm going to defend
this knight. Well, it turns out that black can still
very often play b5.
Because after a cb, ab,
white collapses on the
queen side. If bishop takes b5,
who can tell me the simple and very
powerful move that makes this line work?
This is part of the big reason
that you put your rook on c8.
Of course, rook takes knight.
And as I've explained many times,
two pieces
for a rook usually benefits the minor pieces,
particularly in the middle game
with a wide open center. By the way,
after rook takes c3, we also
have the move knight takes e4,
which is even sexier than queen takes b5,
because we recapture the rook,
and everything starts hanging. You can
analyze this a little bit more
on your own. And if white plays knight takes b5,
then of course we take the queen.
If white plays
rook takes c8 check, we can do
either rook takes c8 or even bishop
takes c8, and we recapture
on a2 with a huge initiative.
In the endgame, after rook d1, we can redeploy
the bishop on e6, and start
tackling this pawn. White is getting tortured here.
So that's
yet another line.
Now, of course, white can play a4
and defend against b5.
Now you should not play b5
because of ab with a discovered attack
on the queen. But any time a4
is played on the accelerated dragon, you should
understand that the b3 pawn becomes
a permanent weakness. What are the tools
available to us to attack it? Well, one
thing we can do is just stick the queen
on this weak square. White
is forced to defend the pawn, but here you have to
remember the maneuver knight f6 to d7.
Some of you were suggesting this move earlier.
Here it's actually very strong
because it opens up an attack on the knight, and the
knight potentially dives into c5.
And also, after rook
fc1, we can now play b5.
ab, ab.
And
if cb, then we win
the knight. And if
knight takes b5, who can tell me
what is the correct sequence
from this position?
This will test if you understand kind of the
idea of b5. I'll be right back.
What's the move here?
Very good. You got it.
Now the key thing to understand
is that very often when you sack a pawn,
you should not rule out a queen trade.
Queen trade doesn't mean anything.
This skewers the bishops.
Now after rook d1,
it's time to start a fire on the other
side of the board. We have
white very much compromised, but
in order to
translate that to an actual
advantage, we have to continually
create threats and challenge white
where he's weak. And in order to do
that, we often have to use our pawn. So this is
another very typical Ixari to dragon idea.
A very timely use of the move
f7, f5.
What is the point of this move? Well, if white
takes on f5, then you play bishop
f5, rook c1. And you can
go either bishop b2 to trap
the rook or knight to c5 when white has
no good way to defend b3. Just look at the
extent of black's domination here.
And you might say, well, I don't understand.
What if white ignores? Well, it's not that
easy to make a move here because white is so
paralyzed. But let's say white
literally plays h3.
Well, now we can play knight c5.
And we're already attacking the e4
pawn. And white starts to collapse here.
White can play b4 to chase the knight away,
but now the knight squeezes into a4
and now c4 is weak. And white
can't move this rook because the bishop hangs.
So, much like the Grunfeld,
the accelerated is about appreciating
the power of piece
activity and the ability
to sacrifice sometimes a pawn, sometimes
even more than that, to achieve this
long-term activity and to understand
that it's not all about—when you sacrifice
something, it's not like you have to win immediately,
right, or win in two or three moves.
You can play for a very prolonged period of time,
let's say, down a pawn, even down a piece,
as long as your other pieces are active.
This is the concept of squeezing
and putting pressure, which is very challenging,
but it's why I'm talking about it,
because we're at a high level now.
Okay, so that was a lot.
Now, there are many
more lines to show here. I will
point out that I don't remember what the—
what Wesley's recommendation
is in his e4 course, like
you guys can tell me, but the main
line, bishop e2, bishop e7, is bishop e3.
The line that used to be
considered best is actually
bishop c1 to g5. At one point,
I think this was considered to be
a very good line. Here,
in contrast, of course, black
has no good discovery because this bishop
is invulnerable,
but our strategy barely changes.
We still play bishop e6. We're still
threatening knight d5, so white
is now forced to drop back to d2.
And now we play
queen a5 once again. We basically
make the same moves against everything.
And another very important thing to understand
is that very often,
white plays bishop h6 in these types of positions.
And this is a bad move.
And the reason why is that you do
give up your fianchettoed bishop, but look at
how weak these pawns are. The simplest
way to pick them off is to play rook a c8.
And white can't play
b3, a very common blunder at a lower level.
Even some GMs have blundered like this
against me. White can
play knight d5 and hit e7,
but after bishop takes d5,
if white takes with a c-pawn, the
e-pawn drops, and if white takes to the e-pawn,
this is another classic scenario.
This is a pawn chain. How do we attack
this pawn chain? Well, you already know that b5
is one of black's main tools
on the queen side. And after c takes b5,
you can take this pawn, or
you can put the emphasis on
peace activity and infiltrate to c2.
Black is the only one having fun.
So,
King's Gambit asks,
what if white pushes f4?
f4 does not create a threat,
and so we can simply continue with our campaign
and play rook a c8. And after b3,
you guys should already understand
what black's move is.
When b3 is played, the first thing you should always test
is whether you can play the immediate
b5. And here you can,
because the queen on d2
is hanging. The move f4 has
severed the connection between the
bishop and the queen, making b5 possible.
There are so many of these lines that I can show you,
but I think that's enough for now. This is like
a good introduction to this line.
I'm sure that we're going to have another game
when we're 2200 or so, and then I'll talk more
about theory.
Yeah, knight takes e4 was not possible.
And the reason is,
sorry, I just wanted to address
this question. So we were talking about
this line, castles castles, bishop b6,
queen d2, queen a5,
f4,
rook a c8, b3. Knight takes
e4 is bad, because white takes on e4.
And when
the smoke clears, white has
two pieces for a rook. Now, black
is all right here, but this is nothing
to write home about. Really nothing to
write home about, because black's rooks are also very, very
bad. There are no open files to
control. And then you might
say, well, but two pieces for a rook, how do
I understand who's better? That's
one of those things that is decided on a
case-by-case basis. It's an imbalance.
And that is why one of the biggest pieces of
advice given to higher-rated players is
to seek positions with a lot of imbalances,
because they are harder
for a lower-rated player to evaluate,
because they require a lot of experience
and understanding to
evaluate properly.
Okay, so you shouldn't be thinking of this in the terms
of, oh, what is the formula
for evaluating this? Two pieces for
a rook is generally good for the two pieces,
so most of the time
you should have a good justification for going
for it if you are the side of the rook.
Okay.
Hopefully that was halfway
sensible. Again, I'll talk
more theory later. Let's address our
opponent's move, f3. I'm going to check
this with the engine. Of course, f3 has been
played many, many times.
Oh, so there's some tactics
here that are interesting.
Yeah, so apparently
Nxd4 is all right,
but not the best move.
The best move, according to the engine, is
indeed Bg7.
White plays Bb3.
And here we have to
rely on a
trap.
I mean, in order to
understand this move,
you have to know the most famous
accelerated dragon trap,
which I've shown before. We've actually
already had it. That trap
occurs when White basically
tries to play it like a regular
dragon. When White plays the move
Bc4,
we castle and White basically tries
to make all the moves that he would make in a dragon.
Who remembers what the
punishment is against this line? What's the famous
trap that Bobby Fischer fell into
against Oscar Pano? It's not
Nxd4. That blunders a piece, but you want to
set that move up with a very
counterintuitive move. And that counterintuitive
move is Qb6. And the whole
point is that the bishop on e3 is
undefended. So White would normally
be able to do something like this. Here,
of course, White's not able to do that.
Now, the common response is Nf5.
But now we grab this pawn on b2
and Black wins the game.
And the reason why... Let me refresh because I
got disconnected. One sec. Sorry.
And the reason why...
And this is important. I know this is a little bit
tedious. You might be yawning if you're watching on YouTube.
But you have to build
the foundations of opening knowledge.
There's just no way around it.
So Nf5, Qb2, hits
the knight on c3. And not only
that, we're also going to win one of the bishops.
So White loses a bunch of pieces
here. If White
plays something like
Bb3... Sorry.
If White plays something like Bb3
to defend the pawn, now
you're able to play Nxc4. This looks
very confusing, but in fact it's very easy to
understand. You now have three
attackers on this knight and only
two defenders. Once again,
this knight is very limited in its scope because
the bishop on e3 is going to drop.
If White plays Nf5,
then we can play Nxc3 and hit
the queen. And in this way, we
evacuate the knight that's hanging.
And if White plays Fe, then we
play Bxd4. Specifically,
Bxd4 to not self-pin.
And we're good. We're fine.
We take with the queen, and we're simply
up a pawn.
White can equalize here,
but it's very hard.
Fischer figured it out against Pano.
So with
this idea under your belt,
it should be easier to understand what the move
is here. Again, it's this queen b6 idea.
Now here, it's even more complicated
because now Nf5 looks quite
a bit scarier. The bishop on g7
drops with check, but
he did fall into the trap, but then Fischer was
able to equalize.
If you calculate further, you
will notice that we quickly win the piece back
because this knight is trapped and the rook
is hanging. So this move
is not scary because
White has no good discovery.
This is a double-check big deal.
We just go Kg8, and we win.
It's scary, but if you know that this
is the move, then it's easy.
White has to defend the rook.
Then we take on g7.
And Black is up a pawn here.
And I think practically this is a very
hard position for White to play because
if White plays a move like
Bte2, which I think is the
logical move, then we stick
the knight right in White's grill, Nt4.
We're threatening a fork.
And if White just ignores
and castles, then
we actually can get away
with Nc2.
Because after Rb1, who can tell
me what the key resource
is for Black? And this is kind of a theme
in these lines.
Yeah, it's simple. Nxc3.
And we take and hit the queen at the
same time. Don't forget about these moves.
And the key is not to automatically
assume, oh, I have to move my queen.
You have to look for moves that
let's say take a piece and simultaneously
attack your opponent's piece.
And when the smoke clears,
Black is simply up a pawn and White has no position
either.
Hopefully that line made sense. There's a lot
more to this. The only other
thing I'd point out, the second most
common move here is Qd2.
And again, you should already be able to tell
what's wrong with Qd2. This walks right
into the trap, Nxc4.
If White
plays, let's test your guys' attention.
If White takes the knight on
c6, should Black play
Nxq
or Qxk, which move?
Try
to calculate.
Yeah, Nxq is the correct move.
Because after
Nxr, we simply play ab.
Material is equal and we are
attacking White's knight. So when the
smoke clears, we're just up a pawn
and we've got a dominant mission.
So Qxk would be a horrible
blunder because it would simply give away
the knight on e4.
Yeah, there are other moves there, but I'm
showing the simplest approach.
What else is there? Of course,
if White plays Fe, then again we play
Bxd4, Bxd4,
Qxd4, and
of course the endgame is
simply miserable for White.
Okay?
So that would have been the correct
approach. It would be simply to play
Bg7 and in response
to Bb3 to play Qb6.
White can also play Nc3 here.
But
here Black wins with a tactic. Who spots it?
Actually, not a lot of people
have found this tactic. I see that
a 2,000 fell
into this in 2021 in a classical
game.
It's not castles. It's not
Nxd4. That blunder is a piece.
It is Nxd4. Great job, Colin.
Same idea.
A lot of people when they see this move
say, well, it doesn't work. White takes this knight,
then we have to take back
and we lose a piece. Again, don't forget
about this concept. We take
White's knight and threaten the queen
simultaneously. Okay? That's the
key. White takes our queen.
We take White's queen.
Now White can win the pawn back here
with a Desperado. Knight takes
f7, but even though White wins the
pawn back, this endgame is still horrible for White.
Look at how passive White is.
Look at how bad these bishops are.
Look at our bishop, and we're going to pile up
on the c4 pawn on the next move with
Bb6 and Rac8, which is an idea that
by now should be very familiar to.
Of course, if White plays Rb1,
then we can chase the rook away with Bf5
and then drop back to e6.
This placement of the bishop
is crucial. Okay.
So, instead, we
took on d4 and played Bg7.
Probably e5 is not the
best that White can do. My guess is that
White should have reverted back to probably
a main line with Nc3.
Then we would have castled, and we would have gotten
something very similar to
the main line. Anyways, let's
focus on e5 because it's already been a while.
Ng8,
Nc3. Okay.
This is all very natural, and here we
sort of came to the first crossroads
in the game where
initially, of course, I was
banking on dxc5.
That is the engine's top choice, but
still, I'm not a huge fan of this position.
The engine simply says,
hey, Bd7, big deal. We're up a pawn.
Evaluation here
is equal. White has enough compensation
for the pawn, but not more
than that.
And if White plays it inaccurately, then White is worse.
So I thought White would go here.
According to the engine, White is supposed to drop back
to e3 just to keep this diagonal
under control.
And here, the engine's top move
is actually Bh6, so you trade off
a pair of bishops, and
simultaneously, you get your knight out of the gate,
and the knight can circle
around through f5.
Now White is supposed to play this very typical
move, c5,
in order to threaten Bb5.
And one way
that the game could bail out
is, well, we can play Nf5,
but that's iffy.
Best is to play Ke8.
And it's important to understand that
in this situation, Nd5
is no longer dangerous because we can simply
bring the rook to c8.
But if you contrast that
to this
situation, because of the presence
of this bishop, Nd5
is now a whole lot more dangerous
because it's not easy
to defend the c7 square.
In fact, here, Black gets checkmated
with Rd8, so this would not be fun.
So
perhaps we should have played De.
We decided to keep the tension. The engine also
likes this move, so Qe4.
And now this
was a very important crossroads, because we
decided essentially to bail out with
dxc5, which of course is fine.
I'm going to check the
engine here, and then I won't over-rely on the engine,
I promise you that.
Okay, so looks like
we did have Qb6.
Oh!
Oh, this is really interesting.
Yeah, this is
very high level. Very high level.
The best move is Qb6.
dxc5, and what we did is 2nd-best, that's just equal.
Black has a slight edge, apparently,
after Qb6. Now, who can remind
me, why did I reject this move?
And why does this move look like it plays into
White's hand? What does it allow
White to do?
You don't have to
remember all of this, folks. If you're trying to remember
all of this, you're doing it wrong.
First of all, this will be up on YouTube,
and you can review it as often as you'd like.
You have to try to understand the ideas,
which hopefully I'm doing a halfway decent job of explaining.
Long castle.
No, come on.
Nb5 maybe, but we can just
chase the knight away here with a6.
So, no, it's long castle.
Now the engine gives this idea.
De, Bb5,
and Bh6++,
already setting a trap.
If the king moves aside,
then Bf5 pins the queen.
White has
to play f4 and intercept.
Now we bring our knight out with tempo.
And White is in some trouble here
because the queen has no good squares.
White can go into the endgame
with Qd4, or White can
trade on f6 and go Nd5.
And this is, right,
when you analyze the engine, like when you have
this position without engine, it would be terrifying.
Looks like White has some
discovery and our king is in the center.
When you look at the engine eval, you'll realize
that White has absolutely nothing
because on the next move you just castle
and you've got two fantastic bishops.
White's king is in permanent
trouble, and again, in such positions
White is always having a hard time
finding a good spot for this bishop
because of this darn c4 pawn.
And if White plays c5,
then we can castle and we can actually
start targeting this pawn
with Ra8 to see it. So whatever White does,
there will be some downside.
So this is high-level
stuff for sure. We decided to play it
in a much simpler way with
Bxe5, and the position is equal.
And h4 was a very interesting idea
by our opponent, followed by h5.
And in this position, White has a forced
draw. This is like the last thing I'll ask
you guys to find, because once
we got into the endgame and we
entered the technical phase of the game,
we're going to go a lot faster and we're just going to
focus on just a couple of the
important moments. We're not going to look at every move.
But White did have a draw
here, and I deliberately avoided saying this
on stream, just in case.
It is Rxh5. But what's
the actual draw here? This is hard to
see.
And this
reminds me of something. Yeah, Qg3 or Qg5.
And
you go back to e5.
And you go back to e5.
And this reminds me
of something.
And the bishop hangs. Now, maybe I would
have played this move, but there's no question
that White is better here. Right?
The spawn structure was ruined. A rook's
coming to d1. The bishop could
come to d3 and create mate threats against
the spawn. This is miserable, so I would
have had to objectively take the draw.
Now, this is a very important
type of tactic which occurs in
a different version.
I've seen this tactic many times.
Let me search up a sample
to help you understand
what I'm talking about.
Let me see if I can quickly and efficiently
find an example.
So,
it's a tactic that relates specifically
to scenarios where the bishop is on e6,
which happens quite often, because e6 is a
standard developing square for the bishop. This is just
some game between
two 2,000s.
And White finds the following idea.
White plays Ra to e1,
forcing
the bishop on e6. And now White finds a very
powerful move. I think a lot of you
would be very tempted to take this
one, but this cashes in too soon
because Black moves the rook and Black is holding on.
White plays Qe3,
a very powerful move, and Black is powerless.
Black tries to get the queen
out of the pin, and
the key, Qe5, threatening
mate, and in order to defend
against the mate, Black has to push the f-pawn,
which relinquishes control over the bishop.
Okay? And that's
the general gist
of what I'm talking about.
Now let's go back to the game.
Yeah, so same concept, right?
You give that check, and in order to defend against
the check, you have to relinquish the control over the bishop.
Something very similar
could happen in a scenario
by the way like this, where
again, you're threatening mate. To defend against
mate, you have to give up a land piece. So what is the
takeaway from this? The takeaway is that when you're
looking at attacking ideas, you
should not forget that one of the most powerful
techniques involves combining
a mate threat with a threat
on an undefended piece.
Yet another type of instantiation
is a scenario where
I'm just getting a random position.
A scenario like
I don't know, like this one, right?
Very often people forget that in such
a situation, you can play Qh6
and you can attack
both the undefended rook and
the h7 pawn. So there's a common
attacking technique which
essentially involves, in a
situation like this, to deliver a
check first, then to play
Qh6 and fork the rook and the pawn.
Rather than going Qh6
immediately, which doesn't attack the rook.
Now hopefully that
gives you a good little in
tactically. That's what our
opponent missed. That is how close he
was to making a draw with Rxh5.
Instead he played the obvious move and
after Qb8, we essentially forced
the queen trade because of the
possibility of diving into g3.
And okay, we could spend another hour analyzing
this endgame. I think the next
stage was pretty straightforward.
A pair of rooks were traded.
We activated our knight. We moved the knight
back to f5. We got
this knight vs bishop imbalance.
We dropped the bishop back to e6.
Now we traded on df6. There was a
bunch of trades and we found this very
important move, Kf8. This was a critical
move, right? So you shouldn't be
unquestioningly afraid of the rook
infiltration to the 7th ring because sometimes you can
do this thing where you drive the rook
out using your rook and your king.
And then we're chilling.
Um...
No, it was not Rzeszewski-Fischer.
It was in fact Fischer-Pano.
Um, it was Fischer-Pano.
Okay, so
there was a question. Why not e5?
Ah, so there's an interesting
suggestion by Amaraldo. Why not to
play e5 first? I didn't
see this move, honestly. This is actually
not bad. Well, I saw
this but I rejected it because of Rxd5.
But on second thought, you can actually go
Rxe6 now and trade
e pawn for c pawn.
Yeah, but okay. But it's not like e5
helps black that much. In fact, I would make the
argument that it seriously
weakens the d5 square.
Right? Because now you can't go e6.
Now you might say, well, here you're
blocking the e pawn but we still reserve
the possibility of playing e6 later
down the line. It's a minor detail.
Okay.
So Kd2.
We play Ke8. Obviously
we set up the threat of Rd8.
And here, I actually think that white makes
a subtle mistake. I think
that white should have tried the move
g5. I think this is the best practical defense
is to play g5. And I
have no idea
whether black is in fact winning
in this pawn endgame. And sometimes even
engines take a long time to evaluate
stuff like this. I'm going to check.
I'm going to check with the engine here
and see if this endgame is winning
for black.
Drumroll, please.
Wow, it's actually currently at equals
over plus. No, it's draw.
It's a draw. And here
is how white draws.
Now this is, oh, this is fascinating.
What do you think
white's best move is here? White is an only
move, apparently, an only move
to draw.
Yeah, everything
else loses.
Wow, this is amazing.
Not c5.
c5 loses.
b4 loses.
f4. Only move is f4.
Now, this is
insanely hard. What would be
my intuitive move? My intuition
would be just to bring the king up to e3.
The reason this draw is
here black has this crazy
tactical idea. You start
with a move that should be very obvious to all
of you. You're trying to counteract the deep
freeze by removing the g5
pawn. Obviously, white's going to go f4.
And here there is a crazy tactic
that wins. This is a very hard move.
Here white is a winning move.
Or black is a winning move, rather.
That winning move
is to play
e5. Absolutely
brazen. You're like, you're allowing
a passer on f6?
And you might be like, well, in this scenario
isn't white just going to create another
passer on the queen side? And then
you're going to get a trouser situation?
Black is winning in this position.
And in order to win, it's now
black who has to find an only move.
To win, black has to play
prophylactically. a5.
Stopping
white from advancing the b pawn.
And as much as possible, slowing
down the process of
creating a passed pawn on the queen side.
Because if white goes here,
then we deep freeze white on the
queen side with a4. This is a technique I
outlined in my endgame video.
So in order to counteract this,
white has to waste the tempo on b3.
What do we use this tempo to do?
Well, we use this tempo to make this
pawn harmless. How do we do that?
Well, of course, by blockading with our king.
White continues to try to create
a passer, but we are just in time.
King f7 hits the pawn. White has to defend
it. White has to defend it.
And now we send our pawn forward.
And we win by a tempo.
Takes, takes, h4.
Threatening h3. White has
to move the king back. We take
f6, and this is an easy win.
Because if white plays
c5, clearly white is
not, white is too tempy
away from creating a queen.
Now if white goes the other way and
tries king to g5, the winning move
is h6 check. This is easier to
understand. And this is a
winning position for black with a very simple
we just go with the king to the queen side.
For instance, after c5,
the easiest way to win is to go king e5,
and then king d4, and
white is way too far away.
After king f5 though,
the winning move is actually king to c3.
It's not king takes pawn because
then white's king makes it back to the center
in time. But here black
is winning because we get to the pawns first.
No, it's crazy.
It's absolutely crazy. If white plays
b4, then we're able just to take twice.
We take c5 and we get a winning king and pawn
endgame.
So it's crazy.
But this is winning.
Now we need to play a5.
If we start by playing king e8,
we give white that extra tempo.
And white uses this
tempo to reach this position
that we talked about. But here
because white's advanced his pawns even further,
and if we try king e5,
what is white's
drawing technique to play b5
and c6 and forcibly
get rid of the b-pawn.
And this is the worst-case scenario
in almost all pawn endgames that you're trying to win.
The quarter pawn is the worst pawn that you can have
because even if you win the a-pawn,
white is just
in time. Tempo for tempo
reaches c2
and reaches a very well-known theoretical
draw.
So
insanity. I mean, the level of
complexity. And this is just a pawn endgame.
So rook endgames have their
own complexity, plus you have
to constantly evaluate
the rook trade, and
often you get pawn endgames that are even more complicated.
So all of that to say
that rook d8 is incorrect.
Oh, sorry. All of that to say
not even that, that white has to play f4
in order to draw. But what on
earth happens if black plays f6?
Right? Isn't this the same thing?
What does white use that tempo to do?
Well, according to the engine,
well, you already have an insight
on this position.
How should white
ensure that the same scenario
does not happen? White has to play
b4. This is what white
gains by starting with f4.
And if black plays
a5 here, and tries
to prevent that from happening,
then white plays b3,
f6, and a3,
and black is just not
in time here. You basically
save a tempo on Ke3,
which turns out to be an unnecessary move.
This is one of those pawn end games
where creating passed pawns is more important
than bringing the king to the center.
So,
that's where white saves that tempo.
And if black tries to do the same thing,
black actually runs the risk of losing.
Black actually
runs the risk of losing.
Here, in fact, black is already lost
because of the trousers.
White wins by playing simply c5,
and then b5 and c6 is a classic
case of trousers. You try to stop
one pawn, and the other pawn
promotes. You try to stop that other pawn,
and the second pawn promotes.
Now, of course, white's king is close enough
to black's pawn majority to keep it at bay
for long enough for white
to promote his pawns. Does that make sense?
Now, of course, here,
you should never forget that if black
simply cannot stop white's pawns,
this is the benefit of a pawn majority.
You can force the door open.
Here, you can play b5, and
both sides have spent a tempo, so neither side
has gained anything.
And so, in this position, black
has to play something like Kd7.
The game goes on, but this is a draw.
White uses his pawn majority to prevent black
from making any progress.
Actually, white gets the king into the center,
and eventually, you reach a scenario where
neither side can make progress.
Black can't make progress because you can't get rid of
the deep freeze, and you can never
set this h-pawn in motion.
Incredible stuff.
All of that to say that after g5,
I maybe would have played Rd8,
but according to the engine,
the best move is Rc8,
Kd3, and now f6, basically
to do the same thing, but keeping the rooks on the board,
which gives you more winning chances.
And if white plays f4,
then again, you play e5.
So even in the rook endgame, this is a very powerful technique.
Crazy.
f takes e5, f takes g5,
and black is winning here, apparently,
because of the three-pass pawns.
And,
wow, this position is also winning for black,
and the reason we played Rc8 is to
keep white tied down to this pawn.
So Ke4 isn't possible,
and these three passers
are going to decide the game.
Okay. Mind-blowing
stuff, but I think that's enough.
Kc3, now we
go e6, and we chase the rook away.
The rook swings over to the b-file.
Again, just to reiterate, if the rook
had gone to d1, it's very important
in rook endgames to not fall asleep
on concrete details. I think a lot of
people would play Rd1 right here.
And forget about Rh1,
suddenly you lose the pawn.
So you have to go Ke7. You have to be
alert and attentive to these
moments, Rh8, and if
white tries to play g5 here, you
already know what the winning
technique is. What would we have done
in the event of g5?
You should already
understand what the process for
ending the deep freeze is.
f6, f4, and what's the move now?
And here it's actually quite obvious that
this move is correct because it doesn't involve any
sacrifices. Yeah, it's e5.
We literally just break through that
deep freeze, and
after fe, we play
fg, and the pass
pawns decide the game. And if
gf here, we don't even need to sacrifice
anything. We simply get this situation,
and again, we have connected passers.
They're just going to push on their own. Our rook
is ideally placed.
Could you start with e5 before f6?
Yeah, you could.
You could play e5 and then f6.
The thing is, it is a waste of tempo
though, because let's think about it mathematically.
The good thing about starting with f6
is that if white actually takes on f6,
you've saved a tempo on e5,
which you don't need to play. Now you can start
pushing your h-pawn.
By playing e5, this is a minor subtlety.
You're giving white an extra tempo,
which could become important because
here, white is a little closer
to creating a pass pawn of his own.
There's no need to give white that tempo. You should only
play e5 in response to f4.
Does that make sense?
In fact,
inviting f4 is a good thing
for black because now we have two
pass pawns rather than one.
Okay, so anyways,
minor points. Our opponent decided
to stay on the 5th rank. Now we play h6,
which I think is a very good move.
Oops, sorry.
F4, Ke7, bringing our king up
and preparing the eventual
Rh8. And here I decided
to take the opportunity to improve
the placement of my rook.
Okay, f4. Now, I'm not going to
spend forever analyzing this with an engine.
I think it's sort of a 50-50 game
in that maybe white can draw this,
but practically speaking, it would be very difficult.
I will point out
I think white went wrong.
White's big mistake
was probably in this position.
I think white had a drawing idea.
And I'm actually going to confirm
this. Yes, I just confirmed this with the engine.
I think this is a serious mistake.
And here white had the same
idea.
Without this idea, white loses. It's a tactical
idea that generates counterplay on the queen side.
Very, very difficult. Let's see
who can spot it. I will give you a hint. There's
something that white can do
on the queen side in order to
favorably transform the pawn structure.
What is it?
Way too slow.
a4, a5, a6. Way too slow. Black's pawn
will be on h2 before you blink.
Not c6.
Too early.
You have to start with rook a5,
but that's the right direction.
Why rook a5? What does this do?
Well, this attacks the a-pawn.
Black plays a6, and now we play
c6, breaking apart the pawn
chain. And in so doing,
white creates this weakness
that black now has to burn a tempo to
defend, but most importantly,
white creates a passed pawn of his own
that can be used as a bargaining chip,
making it more difficult and giving the
rook more tasks.
So just a good technique to have in your
library of ideas, right? You attack
a pawn, force it forward,
and then you overload the other pawn.
And I've seen this kind of thing before.
Without this idea,
white just does not have the defensive firepower
to keep this pawn at bay.
Maybe this is still a draw miraculously,
but again, I think it's becoming harder and harder.
And very importantly,
we found the right opportunity
to play e5. We're threatening to create
a protected pass where we force the white
to take, and already I think this is a winning endgame.
King d5. I thought I
played it very accurately. And this idea
which I found was, I thought,
very, very powerful, this rook on h5.
Now you might say, well, how did
you know that the rook belongs there?
I actually had a game, if I remember
correctly, where I
had kind of a similar
type of idea.
Basically, the point is that
you want to extract the most
benefit from your rook.
In general, in rook endgames,
because you have so few pieces, you want
your rook to be playing to its fullest potential.
And there was a game long ago where I
was able to save the game by
kind of following that rule of using the rook
to perform and fulfill
as many tasks as possible. I was able
to draw a GM in a game that I
should have lost.
So, this is the position that I had
against that GM.
Now,
it's a very difficult position for white.
But I was able to find
a very interesting drawing technique.
Basically, you ask
yourself, what does black want?
What black wants to do
is to simply advance this king forward.
I was able to find a
unique fortress by playing e5.
Two concepts are at
play here. The first is, again, I would
call this using the pawn as a bargaining chip
where you might be afraid of something
like rook b5, but you don't have to be because
the moment black takes the e-pawn with the rook,
we take the b-pawn and this is an obvious draw.
Black, of course, plays
king e6. Now the rook switches
over to e8. And my opponent
started to realize that he can't make progress
because if he drives the king up,
the rook drops down to e7,
and you're able to win the f7 pawn
and then quickly run the king over
to the other side of the board.
If white goes king d7,
I threw in this move,
and I go back to b8. And no matter
what black does, anytime
the king goes up to e6, the rook
temporarily moves away from its ideal
post to chase the king back down.
And my
opponent kept trying it, he
failed, and then my rook was able to cut off
the king, and eventually I was
able to force white to give this pawn away
and then get my king to the right spot
in order to draw the game.
Why was
e5 important here?
Let's say you try to play this without e5.
Let's say you go king f1.
Maybe this is not a great example.
Oh, I was afraid of f6.
I was afraid of this move.
And I think what you're
able to see here is that
it's very hard for white's rook to do everything
at once. If you go
rook f8 and try to do the same thing,
black's king basically squeezes through
to a much more
dangerous square. You're basically
trying to keep the king boxed in. It's not
an ideal example, but again, I'm just trying to
help you understand the bigger picture,
which is to try to maximize the potential
of each piece, particularly the rook.
And it doesn't
always mean, you know,
you shouldn't have a preconceived notion of what an
active rook looks like.
That's kind of the secondary
concept here.
Because you might look at this and say,
this rook seems really passive because it's
quote-unquote tied down
to the protection of these pawns. Well, that's
one way of looking at it, but it's also tying
white down, right?
Because it's tying down the king, it's
keeping the king fully at bay.
Notice how all of the infiltration squares are protected.
And most importantly, it's keeping the rook
at bay. Any time the rook moves, we push the pawn.
Now, the last concept
that I want to highlight
is in this position
where I missed that white
was able to infiltrate from behind with
king f6. And white
could reach a very similar position
to the one in the game,
but I still think black is winning. And I think we
win in exactly the same way that we won the game.
We go b5, then we go
king a4, and then we give up the h-pawn
for the b-pawn, and we convert via the
Lucina method. So we go here, here.
We go here.
We go rook c8 to cut
off the king. And any time
white takes the pawn, we take on a3.
This is a theoretical win. This is a Lucina position.
So the king is just
unable to make it to the c-file.
But I'll analyze this a little bit more
on my own. This is getting a little bit too high level.
For all intents and purposes, this is
a winning endgame. This is almost impossible
to save.
But I've bored you enough
with this endgame. Our opponent
gave up a6. I took with the king.
Notice what I did here.
The reason I didn't take with a pawn is because
having a corner pawn often
referred to in a lot of rook endgames
and pawn endgames. So even though it's counterintuitive
to go backward, I thought the tempo
was less essential than
keeping that b-pawn.
Which also immobilizes
the a-pawn with the move
b5.
Okay.
So
in any case, we go b5.
Now we give up one of the pawns
strategically, but we
cut off the king. And last
thing, what if white had avoided
taking the
h4 pawn? Well, we could force
white to take that pawn with a move like
rook to g8, followed by rook
to g3. Okay.
So white is just not able to
make it to the right area
of the board at the right time.
White's just not in time. We go b4, b3,
b2. And notice how the rook actually
cuts the king off along the third rank,
so it's ideally placed on this square.
If white plays
rook takes h4, then you kind of know the drill.
And the side checks are easily
parried by bringing the king
back to a4, and then blocking
with a pawn. So the side checks are never like,
it's never perpetual check here,
because you basically use the same technique
again and again. You go king a3,
and then you go b3.
And then king a2 and b2. You should remember that
technique of dealing with side checks.
And that's the basic
premise for winning this game. Now the way
our opponent played it, the only thing you have
to know here is the technique of putting the king
behind the pawn in order to advance the pawn
one step further. Essentially pulling yourself
up by the bootstraps. And then finally
no Lucina needed, you just go rook a8,
you choose the file
that you will protect, and then you
put the king on that file, and you promote
the pawn. And that
concludes this very, very
complicated game. I basically only scratched the
surface of the endgame, but we've been going
well over an hour, and it's 4.
I need to go to sleep because we've got commentary
today. Technically, it's already
light outside.
I hope you enjoyed. Any questions?
Yeah, very, very well played by
our opponent, so big congratulations to our opponent.
I mean, last speedrun game since
I hit 2,000, I've been legitimately
hard. And I mean
this to compliment my opponents.
So really, the
key takeaway, our opponent played perfectly
and should have played rook h5
and found this draw.
Where I probably would have played f6
and risked it, but I would have run the risk of losing
this game.
Yeah, the big endgame book that I would recommend
is 100 Endgames You Must Know. I would
recommend the Chessable version. Great
introduction to, like, not only
the actual endgames that you must know,
but it also contains great endgame essentials
for, like, getting the hang of
a lot of positions. Thank you
everybody, and I'll see you tomorrow.
Endgame music